[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
for today's video i'm going to be doing
something a little bit different
as the channel has been around for a
little while now i felt that it was
about the right time
to make a q a type video last week
i asked you guys in the community tab to
leave me whatever questions that you may
have
regarding me the channel or anything
else i also asked you to avoid questions
that may involve too much deep diving
into the law
as those types of questions probably
weren't a video in and of themselves
i've hand-picked some questions that i
felt were appropriate for this video
and if you want your question answered
in the next q a video
then be sure to keep an eye on the
community tab where i post channel
updates quite frequently
if i don't end up getting through many
of these and the video is getting quite
long
don't worry i'll pick up where i left
off in another q a
without further ado let's get into it
question number one
is from rishikesh who asks is youtube
your full-time career
or you're doing it as a hobby the answer
to that is that youtube
is now as of roughly july my full-time
career
prior to that i was working in marketing
i dedicate a ton of time to the channel
and i work now more than ever but i'm
doing what i love and i wouldn't change
it for anything
this is my absolute dream job and i want
to thank you all for making it possible
question number two is from crackle eu
who asks
when did you first read harry potter as
the books were steadily being released
as i was growing up
i didn't have access to them all right
away so i read them at different times
however the philosopher's stone was
given to me by my grandfather
in 1998 or 1999 when i was six or seven
that was when i first had exposure to
the books i guess that's where it all
started
question number three is from
coolscratcher who asks
why do you say you're a wizard harry at
the end of some videos
and why only some good question when i
first started the channel i knew that i
needed an outro of some kind
and so i eventually decided to use
quotes as a way of ending videos
initially i flip-flopped between wanting
to use different quotes each
time and just using one of my favorites
you're a wizard harry
your wizard arry was my go-to outro at
the start
but for a while now i've been using
different ones and my goal at this point
in time
is to use a different quote each video
question number four is from
newsie k who asks who's your favorite
character
and who's your favorite marauder let me
start with my favorite character
this is not an easy question for me to
answer particularly as i like
most of the characters in harry potter
in their own unique ways
however if i had to choose one i think
i'd go with snape
if you would ask me this question midway
through the story then this answer might
have been different
the fact that he's grey always made him
intriguing to me and i always found his
level of power and perceived
complete understanding of magic to be
quite interesting
i think that if snape had managed to
stay alive he could have possibly been
one of the most powerful wizards to have
ever lived whatever the book
show i've always liked grey characters
as there is a lot more to
interpret the traditional good bad
dynamic can be a bit exhausting at times
and so i found the grey characters to be
a bit of a breath of fresh air
as it allows for us to decide for
ourselves where this character stands on
the moral spectrum
as for a favorite marauder i think i
would have to go with
sirius black pettigrew is definitely out
of the equation
as is james for tormenting snape i enjoy
remus quite a bit
but sirius edges him out by a little
question number five is from haroon
23 who asks favorite harry potter movie
and character
i've answered character already but if i
had to choose a favorite movie
i think i would go with either
philosopher stone or order of the
phoenix
philosopher's stone certainly gets a lot
of points for being the first film
created
as it helped introduce us on screen to
the magical world that we know and love
the nostalgia that i feel when watching
the first film is unparalleled by
anything else
which even as a standalone point brings
it near the top however i think i
enjoyed the order of the phoenix the
most
over the years the harry potter films
got darker and darker
slowly evolving from the state of
childhood innocence in the first film
to the sheer darkness of the last the
order of the phoenix for me
lies in that sweet spot where it's
neither too dark nor too innocent
it's in a place where we can appreciate
the lighter side of the magical world
and the darker without going into a
full-on movie review
i think that the order of the phoenix
encapsulates all the key thematic
elements of the harry potter story
while providing us with a stimulating
on-screen experience
so much happened in that film from
dementors attacking harry and dudley
to umbridge taking over hogwarts to
sirius black dying
to voldemort and dumbledore's fateful
duel ootp
has it all question number six is from
forks
who asks how do you feel about warner
brothers removing johnny depp from the
franchise
i honestly don't know enough about
johnny depp's situation with amber heard
to
properly comment on it but i do think
that johnny depp is a great actor
and i think he did a decent job in the
role from a continuity perspective i'm
not a fan of switching out actors
but i think that as we are still
relatively early on in the five part
series
it should give us enough time to adapt
mars mickelson is about as good as it
could have gotten
for a recast so i'm interested to see
how things pan out
question number seven is from enrique
robles who asks
do you think we'll ever get a movie
adaptation of the cursed child odds of
getting a movie on james and lilly
potter growing up
leading up to their deaths i'll start
with the second part
i don't think that we're going to get a
movie on james and lilly but what i do
anticipate at some point in the future
is perhaps a harry potter show that
might dive into some of the minutia of
character backstories
maybe that's just wishful thinking as
for the cursed child
i don't think that we'll get a movie
adaptation and i say this because the
play is not well liked amongst most
harry potter fans
would i watch the movie yes am i eagerly
awaiting its creation
no i do appreciate the story but i think
that's only because my mind
is able to compartmentalize it and
separate it from the harry potter story
altogether
i'm not a fan of the canon that it
suggests
question number eight is from karthik r
who asks
what is your hogwarts house wand and
patronus i'm going to post either a live
stream or a video of me being sorted
having my one selected patronus selected
at one point or another
obviously i have had it all done before
but i think i'd like to run through all
of it properly in a video
or video series and reveal the true
answers then what about you guys
what house are you in let me know in the
comment section down below
question number nine is from heather
long who asks
is there any other series that has
captured your imagination or interest as
harry potter has
bonus question who is your favorite
marauder i've answered the second pass
already
as far as another series capturing my
imagination in the same way as harry
potter
that's a tough one i will say this i am
a big lord of the rings and token fan
i've obviously read all the books and
seen all the movies
and it has a special place in my heart
but it's never been quite as much of an
interest of mine as harry potter has
been
lord of the rings is both impressive and
fascinating because the law
is truly deep if there's a character
place or even
object it captures your attention in
that series there's probably more
information about it out there than you
can conceivably digest
my other big interest is mythology
particularly greek mythology which got
me through my long commutes to
university for a number of years
the number of audiobooks i've listened
to books i've read on it are vast
and they probably know more about greek
mythology specifically than i do
harry potter i've actually considered
starting a mythology channel
so if that's something that you guys
would be interested in then let me know
i would probably cover greek roman norse
etc
question number 10 and i think the final
question of this video
i will continue with another q a soon is
from hardik nagaria
who asks what will you choose butterbeer
or bertie bott's every flavour beans
when i went to universal studios a
number of years ago i tried butter beer
and wasn't a fan at least of that
version of butter beer
i would imagine that real butter beer is
much nicer than what i had
however i can't forget that taste so i
will have to go with birdie box beans
and that's it for today's video i will
continue this q a in a video next week
so if you want to be included in that
keep commenting on the same community
tab post
as i will be grabbing questions from
there i hope you all have a wonderful
rest of the day until next time remember
age is foolish and forgetful when it
underestimates youth you